oh okay so that
should be working
this should be all set
yes
[Laughter]
okay
so
uh there's gonna be a few things a
little
unusual about this one
um
we are first of all we're going very
um kind of loose
with with this one
um
we're just doing yeah you may have
already guessed I am trying to entertain
a dog uh we might get briefly
interrupted just because there's a few
things going on in the house at once and
I may also get heckled
because regulars to the live stream may
be familiar with Meg
she's currently sitting over there
uh yes no she's not really sitting over
there
so if if you uh
if you hear anything uh it's your
imagination
all right Archie yes all right hold on
people are gonna want to see you they're
gonna get mad at me if I don't show you
is here's Archie
here's here's the little man
say hi to the people
okay fine
now you go
as I said
um there was a
Fair bit going on all at once
um and I may have to pause the stream
briefly at one point but here's the main
thing we're doing since this is the
first
um major thing that I am doing for pride
month we're gonna do
some gay
yay for gay
so
um this is going to be more uh tier
ranking stuff which I like to do live
it's a lot of fun to do live but
um in addition
this is going to be all
both geeky and queer at the same time so
hopefully we'll have fun with this
um because of the way I have my setup
and I don't have more than one monitor I
cannot watch the chat while I'm doing
the tier list stuff
um so that does mean that
um super chats are something I won't be
able to address until towards the end of
the stream and I will deal with them
then but uh
but yeah I hope folks have fun anyways
mild chaos today that's the theme it's
uh it is it is chaos but let me switch
that all right
so the first tier that we are going to
be the first tier ranking we're going to
be doing is you know what is it actually
called
um okay it's rating uh it's basically
doing queer headcanon for Marvel
characters that have appeared in movies
it's not necessarily the MCU we're gonna
have some X-Men stuff in here as well
but you'll see the spectrum that we have
we have
um masculine gay you know MLM lesbian
bisexual pansexual asexual trans
demisexual non-binary and uh CIS
straight Ally and also aromantic now I'm
gonna have to put them all somewhere on
here there are no options for like oh no
like uh homophobe or anything like that
which I suppose is nice so uh
theoretically even as we deal with
villains at least they're still
inclusive
I'm just going to do this in the order
that they come up because they seem to
be in no particular order at all and we
start with Scott Lang Ant-Man
I really don't get gay Vibes off him
I'm just gonna go with uh CIS straight
Ally for that one I know that the love
of Paul Rudd does kind of transcend
um sexualities for some folks but I get
very straight Vibes off him
next up Beast tank McCoy from the X-Men
movies hmm
what we know he has
um uh attraction to the feminine because
he has his crush on Mystique so we know
about that
Honestly though
I do wonder sometimes about you know the
extended period in which it seemed like
he and Charles were living together and
I don't get a totally straight via vibe
off of him I'm gonna go buy for that one
Dr Steven strange hmm
so all right
we again know we know there is a
traction towards Femmes because he has
uh Rachel but that never seems to fully
go anywhere
um well unless unless you also count the
what if stuff which I don't wanna
because I don't like it so where do we
want to put you
you I'm you know what
I'm gonna go with demisexual he doesn't
seem to have a very high degree of
Attraction except for Rachel and that's
someone that he knows really well so I
think he needs that emotional connection
and like he's also a workaholic so it
seems like the only thing that breaks
that is when he's got the emotional
connection going on oh well this one's a
gimme that's Deadpool Deadpool's pan
that's Canon well it's canon in the
comics they've kind of been wishy-washy
about it in the films which has annoyed
me slightly I wish they just commit to
it especially given that they went with
an R rating anyway it's not like
confirming it was gonna ruin their PG-13
but whatever
so let's see what else we got
um oh we have Star-Lord
um
I I get nothing but bro Vibes off him
and yeah and not in that you know
sometimes Bros hang out and make out
kind of way just just normal straight
bro so we're gonna go
um Ally straight sis
Wanda
huh
well she ain't straight I feel very
confident in saying that here's the
thing
her primary attraction and relationship
was with an Android now a masculine
presenting Android yes
but it really it it makes me hesitant to
call just a normal straight relationship
so
um I think I'm going to go
I think I'm gonna go pansexual
I think it's more of a an attraction to
the person whatever their gender may be
as opposed to specifically being
attracted to them for their gender
presentation
that's my current understanding of
pansexual versus bisexual I know
different people have different
definitions some people get hung up on
the idea that bi means two I used to
it's weird We're Not Gonna We're Not
Gonna litigate that today
uh oh her brother so we have the MCU
version of quicksilver
huh
you know what
I'm gonna go gay
I'm gonna say that that little taunting
he did of uh of Hawkeye I think that was
him flirting
so we're gonna go gay for that one
oh
whatever cat dennings's character was
named
I can't remember now
she she was just kind of Kat Dennings
but in the MCU am I wrong
I'm not a character witness
[Laughter]
all right
um
goodbye I get bisexual bisexual vibes
I can talk
um off her just generally so we'll go
there
oh
so we've got Jane Foster
mostly seeing her with attractions
towards
the male presenting I'm trying to think
is there wiggle room on this
hmm
hmm and also like I'm realizing now as I
look at this in some cases I'm gonna
have to make a judgment call because you
know being say for instance trans does
not preclude one from also being
pansexual or lesbian or whatever else so
I'll have to at some point I'm gonna
have to decide which one's more
important with some of these
um because there's plenty of cases where
some of these overlapping you would not
just be one you'd be multiple but we
work with the template as we have it
yeah
nope maybe no
I don't know what's going on in my own
home
Welcome to My Life
Jane Jane Jane Jane Jane Jane
um
no I think I'm just gonna go straight
Ally
ER hmm
again we know the confirmation of uh
attraction primarily towards the
feminine
we know his brother is all over the
place but
he certainly wasn't judgy
so Thor feels like Ally material
like you know what if there was a
category for for heteroflexible
I'd put Thor there
but they don't give me that option so
we're just gonna go uh Ally Street Black
Widow Black Widow is bi as
like that one's not even a question ah
the fox X-Men version of quicksilver
hmm
you know what
I'm not sure I've got a full
justification for why
I kind of get non-binary vibes off him
like the movie season are set in like
the wow God they went multiple decades
but characters never seem to age but you
know 70s 80s I don't think he had the
word
to describe himself that way but I feel
like I feel like that fits or at least
I'm gonna decide that it does so
Wolverine ooh
Logan what do we do with you
honestly I would kind of prefer to put
Logan in a romantic or asexual but
that's straight up headcanon and it's
contradicted not only in the movies but
also in the comics so I don't think I
can justify that
you know what though
feel like he might fit under Demi for
kind of a similar reason to Doctor
Strange which is that he he can be very
single-minded he's also grumpy as hell
and
I don't know then again when he has his
attraction to Gene that's pretty much
immediate that's even before he gets to
know her so that might not fit
I really don't want to put him as as
straight I really don't I think I have
to though
[Laughter]
uh I don't know if the mic is actually
picking her up but I just got the um
from the background
Nick Fury
we
not I don't think we've ever seen any
hint of Attraction from him
like he's he's married to the work and
happily so
I
feel like either asexual or aromantic
would actually work for him
I'm gonna go I'm gonna go asexual on
Nick Fury
yeah okay so Valkyrie
I gotta decide if Valkyrie goes under
buy or pan
without getting bogged down in
litigating the difference all over again
um
I
actually why am I even thinking that
lesbian
I think lesbian fits better I know we've
had some hints at some uh attraction
towards men but like I don't know that
feels more like she's messing with them
to me we're gonna go lesbian
Captain America
he's very much an ally
he's very straight he's very
understanding he will fight for your
rights but he's like dudes dudes pretty
damn straight
if there was an option for closeted
Maybe
because just given the time he comes
from I'm not sure he could
fully parse anything that might have
been going on
but
we don't have that option so we will
just go with straight
nebula ooh
nebula I'm gonna go aromantic
nebulous bonds seem to be rooted in
you know they seem to be familial or
sort of Branch out from that you know a
sense of family we don't really get a
lot of romantic hints I could I could
picture her potentially well I don't
mean picture as in rule 34 create a
mental never mind I'm down this Rabbit
Hole now I could picture her
having sex
but I have a hard time picturing her
being in romantic love so I'm gonna go
with aromantic
falcon
another one who
gut instinct says real straight real
real straight let me think though
nah he's he's real damn straight he's so
straight it's it's crazy how straight he
is
so we know she has attractions to the
masculine because we have a whole thing
with
I cannot remember the character's name
Daniel kaluya was the actor and I've
I don't remember the character's name
dang it
um anyway let's see
I feel like like her emphasis when
talking with him was all focused on love
I think her main thing is attraction to
the
emotionality in the relationship
rather than being Raleigh off the
physical so we're gonna go pansexual
with her
pepper pots ooh
what do we do with you I mean if she is
straight she's a big Ally feel
comfortable with that
um
trying to think
if she indicated
clear attractions outside of Tony
um
like I feel like there's some references
to her
canceling dates or something
um
and because of having to deal with his
nonsense
I don't know I'm I think I'm gonna go
um Demi with her I think I think she
needs the uh the emotional link ah
Mystique Mystique is trans
Mystique is trans by Nature she freely
like Mystique is gender fluid is what
she is and gender fluid is a form of
Trance so it falls under the trans
umbrella she's trans don't argue with me
she is also
the queerest damn icon I did a whole
video on what a queer icon she is so
check the backlog uh who the hell is
that oh that's
um
freaking Giles from
from you know uh yeah
from Agent Carter
ah okay
whoo
I barely remember Agent Carter I'm gonna
have to strain a little for this one
[Music]
um
you know what
he's too Dapper to be straight
I can't remember
if he ever showed attractions
towards women I'm just gonna I'm just
gonna go with gay
it feels right I didn't finish the
second season of that show not because I
didn't like it just because I just kind
of fell off it never came back you know
time but uh I'm gonna go with that and
if people tell me that's wrong
I don't care
uh MJ oh MJ's not straight at all we're
going bisexual energy on that
Peggy Carter
Peggy Peggy Peggy
I
I don't think she'd have been ready to
admit to it
again given the time in which she lived
but I'm gonna go pansexual for that one
who's this oh God we're just moving down
the
down the line with this so then there is
Sharon Carter
I just get bisexual energy off her
actually you know what no
no we're going lesbian on her because
that kiss that she shared with Steve was
awkward as hell and not just because
she's the niece of his old girlfriend
dude but like also just seeing it it was
weird it was awkward it felt unnatural I
don't think her heart was in it I think
she was trying to be straight when she
really isn't we're going lesbian on that
one
um oh it's is it Jimmy
from Ant-Man and also he showed up in
one division hmm Jimmy Jimmy
I feel like
I feel like Jimmy's the kind of guy who
would get slightly confused when
somebody asked them so what what do you
find attractive I think his answer would
probably just be magic tricks so we're
gonna put him under asexual
um
Peter Parker not just Peter
this specific one
because like if we were talking Toby
Maguire I just go straight Ally Andrew
Garfield
probably the same
this one though the MCU Peter
hmm
I am debating this a little bit
definitely strong preference for
um for the if I'm presenting certainly
hmm
Peter Peter Peter I'm gonna come back to
you actually you're you're stumping me a
little bit uh Agatha is just bisexual
villain energy all over
uh Roadie Roadie's roady's really really
straight
yeah
yeah that's
hang on let me think
get
okay
you know what I'm gonna properly indulge
some headcan in here
Roadie is
I can't think of any way to put it other
than somewhat performatively masculine
like he's
he's often feeling like he's in
competition with Tony uh in a way that
like feels like he's he's trying to
measure up to that like maybe that's not
his natural state of being but you know
he's just trying to find a way to
perform masculinity because he wasn't
raised that way I'm a head Canon Roadie
as trans
there we go
because I can
because it's my tier ranking
ah
Monica Rambo
hmm
we don't get much in the way of
indications for her
she has that kind of very dedicated to
the world you know I think
I feel comfortable putting her under
Demi
Magneto uh
so
if we take on board that this Magneto is
also the same one as later they're like
we're a lot of hints of a thing between
him and Mystique except that you know
what a gay man understands the glory
that is mystiqs inherent queerness he's
gay he's yeah he's just gay
Hawk Eye
yeah yeah yeah straight I was trying to
think if there was oh
shut down hard for even suggesting an
Inkling
straight
okay
that takes care of that one
he's a Survivor but he's straight he's
straight no yep
yeah yeah no I I can't even I can't even
um pretend to argue otherwise
ah the thing Ben Grimm
hmm
let's see I feel like like the part of
me wants to try and put him somewhere
else but I think straight allies the
only thing that really makes sense for
him
so yeah
I I won't I won't belabor it we'll just
go with uh we'll just go with that
so
I really should figure out what to do
with Tom Holland I keep skipping over
him all right
oh will you now
Maybe not today I really I really hope
the mic is picking you up cleanly I
really do
uh uh on the off chance that it isn't
her answer to that was oh I could tell
you what you could do with Tom Holland
with that in mind
you know what
I'm gonna put him under pan I can't even
fully justify that it just feels right
we're going by vibes
Tony hmm
yeah Tony's just straight
[Music]
no no he's not
Tony has little moments of appreciation
little snide remarks he's not he will
always perform straightness he will
always identify straight
he's behind He's just never gonna open
up about that
it's gonna be something that he's just
living within the back of his head
that's true too
not not that being bisexual
automatically makes you no no but
no wait a minute are you also in the
chat I don't
everywhere
oh goodness gracious
you're trying to sneak this in on me oh
and to see people here we can hear me
it's like oh we can hear you loud and
clear that I noticed there you are right
there in the CH not me
uh-huh okay
anyway read Richards Mr Fantastic
problematic straight dude
I don't have a category for problematic
so we're just gonna go straight like
he's so father's Father Knows Best it's
it's frustrating
it's just not great
Colossus hmm
[Music]
honestly this version of Colossus kind
of feels Ace to me
yeah
I just I don't think he's got the
instincts
oh God Johnny Storm yeah straight
so that that's both Chris Evans
character straight but like
again I kind of wish I had a
like a category that worked for like as
opposed to straight Ally like straight
douchebag
because that's where Johnny Storm and
also Reed Richards should be
but uh these allies all I've got Loki
now Loki
the question is bye
pan
I want to put trans I want to put trans
so bad the problem is
the Loki series wouldn't commit to the
idea of
um Sylvie not just being a random female
variant but like literally having been
like Loki and choosing to change because
that would indicate that that was part
of the inherent nature or in the mix for
Loki just as a template for all the
variants but they have not confirmed
that yet they better next season if they
dance around it again that's going to
annoy the hell out of me so let's go
with bye
Charles Xavier
yes yes yes so
uh yeah we'll put him right there next
to his boyfriend
there are hints of a potential romantic
thing between him and Mystique I don't
buy it I've never bought it and I
honestly think the only reason he went
for it is because uh she could have
appeared male to him
so
Zemo
you know what I think it's something
about the fur on the collar
it just it just says non-binary to me
something something about the Swagger
and the fur line code
I don't know it's a feel
to Chala
I don't
I don't think I can rationalize putting
him anywhere other than straight but boy
what an ally
ABS absolute I mean literally absolute
King
Drax you know drax's pan
actually no Drax is Demi there we go
like that that doesn't we know it has
happened he had a wife he had a kid but
like
he's just not building the connections
that are gonna that are gonna get him
there again and I think he'll be okay
with that Gamora
let's see
the thing is I'm tempted to be a little
bit of a
and rank this as the Gamora we last saw
in Guardians who I actually think might
be kinda Ace
um but
honestly what they're really talking
about is the Gamora that we saw the most
of the one who died and we know she had
an attraction to Peter
but I don't know like the idea of
putting someone who is not human like an
alien species as straight never strikes
me as correct like that seems always
very much like a human hang-up
so we are going to go with pan for her
shuri
tree
that
actually you know what
I feel like
asexual fits for her
she's attracted to Tech
that's kind of her thing
um
you okay yes
we sure yes okay
uh
so let's see
so oh Bruce Banner
I didn't say anything what was that
noise though
you didn't have to say anything that you
made a noise what was that noise
I'm trying see now I'm trying to figure
out what that noise for Bruce Banner was
that noise for Mark Ruffalo
where's Banner okay
all right
I'm tempted now to put him under gay
just to mess with you
uh I can't justify that though
um
he's he's the occasionally problematic
straight problematic because he just has
anger issues
stressed out
this is true
he's too stressed out for anything
ever
true this is and if honestly if we
didn't have the confirmation of
attractions to multiple people I'd be
tempted to put him under either a
romantic or asexual because like you're
too stressed to have a to have a
relationship but the thing is we have
seen him so yeah
is lovable yeah no fair enough sorry
hang on one second folks
all right
so it was oh Howard Stark oh dude
too damn sure Act actually you know what
got that Classic Hollywood like
sort of Errol Flynn style Suave that
makes you go like
I know you got a lot of women
but that's not all you got
we're we're gonna say like father like
son on that one
Susan storm uh uh Susan
I I I I
specifically talking about the movie
iteration because I actually think Sue
storm can be interesting in the comics
but
I can't
I barely buy the relationship that
you're in much less the idea of you
being with anyone of another gender
actually you know what that said
I'm wondering if I can justify putting
her in
uh asexual array romantic because it
really feels like she's in these
relationships out of a sense of
obligation
which like The Meta reason for that is
just the actors had no chemistry but
in universe
now they're just a bad fit they're just
a bad fit for each other it's not that
she doesn't have attraction it's just
she's for some reason won't leave this
guy all right
Carol Danvers Carol's got
Carol's got definite queer energy I just
gotta figure out where I want to put her
honestly we're just gonna go lesbian
there have been some uh excellent uh
explanations as to why it makes total
sense that she was in a loving
relationship with Monica's Mother Maria
so we're just gonna roll with that
accepted as headcanon mantis
mantis strikes me as incredibly Ace
um again just sort of like
would have to have the concept of sexual
attraction explained to her
and Bucky
what are we going to do with you
Bucky
you know what Bucky I said Steve is
straight
but I don't think you are
I I think Steve loves you completely
platonically I think you love Steve
a little bit more than platonically
so we're going I have um affirmations
from the peanut gallery
and to round it out we have
oh God why am I why have I lost the
character's name
oh my God
starts with an n
all right I'm gonna check that now
because that's gonna bug me
and I'm sure the uh the chat is probably
shouting it at me or they will be in a
moment
Nakia there we go I knew it started with
an n
all right
I felt like
I felt like uh Bruce Campbell and
Army of Darkness
nectar nickel noodle it was an N word
anyways Kia Nakia Nakia
I just get I just get by
I just
that just makes sense to me
all right we do have another tier that
we are going to do uh we are going to be
doing
um
an owl house one next
um all right people are saying they
can't see the bottom of the screen
Jen Walters is not on it's not a uh it
is not a complete list
um and no moon moves like I'm not gonna
be doing DC because I don't know DC as
well and also I didn't find a tier to
queer up uh DC uh in truth
so
um I'm gonna pop in real quick
Super Chat from John vinyls thank you
very much random silly head Canon that
wama wink from Centaur world is bisexual
oh I buy that I buy that she is a
disaster by
she's she's one of those
all right so let's
switch this over
to the owl house let me make sure I've
got this lined up the way I want it
and do that and let's
expand that out this way
shift that over there we go
because you know it's fun to you know
take characters from a ostensibly quite
straight universe and mess around with
them let's let's deal with characters
from a super queer property because hell
yeah
so this isn't even figuring out
specifically what they are this is
ranking on the degree of queerness we
have Queer on every level a little queer
closeted queer straight Ally and
homophobe
and let us see
I think we'll just go down in the order
we've got them
we've got loose
over here we've got Amity here we've got
Ida we've got Willow let's start with
Amity Amity
I mean Amity is queer on every level and
I'll probably speculate a little on
specifics Amity I do think is a straight
up lesbian loses by we know that they
actually let them say that in the show
and it was wonderful
huh not enough things do that
eat it oh
it is eat is not even a little bit uh
straight she's Queer on every level
Willow
will I actually think is less
queer than the others which is
odd because the kind of character that
she is in a in a more straight show
I would think of her as
the queerist in a straight show but in a
show this queer she's actually notably
less so than the others she's still a
little queer though
um
are we going to do with you
I'm trying to think because I know it's
I know like a lot of people have a lot
of queer ships for him
uh I'm just gonna go with a little
though I think
Hunter
Hunter's a little he's he's on there but
like look look at who's at the top tier
he's he's not at that level he just
is not
um
let's see what else we got here
um oh the twins
huh
I feel like she's come to terms with it
I feel like he's still he's still got a
journey to have
and like he hasn't sorted himself out
yet oh
Adalia uh homophobe
like
realistically of all the stuff she's got
going on it's not necessarily a
requirement she might just be a terrible
person overall but like it fits
everything else about her
so cleanly it's just like yeah
yeah
I can never remember the name of amity's
father
I'm gonna go with Ally
for him
like I debated like maybe a little
closeted which might even like make for
some of the strain between him and his
wife I I think he's straight
but he's yeah he's well we know he's an
ally her no God she's the worst
uh Willow's dads
the thing is I know okay
it might sound it might seem odd that
I'm putting them in a little queer as
opposed to Queer on every level just
because it's like
it's it it's a same gender pairing that
is the exact nature of what they are
what are you doing
um that having been said like
there's being Queer as an identity as in
like just having a queer identity
and then there's what I think qualifies
as Queer on every level which is just to
be so
um not necessarily flamboyant but just
like to be uh like nobody
who gets put in at least in my mind in
the queer on every level category should
you be able to glance at and think I
don't know I feel like if those two
weren't next to each other you could
glance at them and go maybe I'm not sure
so for that reason they go in a little
queer
uh oh this little tool
um I'm gonna go with closeted for him
not as anything specific I just feel
like he's still sorting himself
oh v v is V is queer on every level and
it's great and I love it again a bit
like Mystique you can't argue anything
other than some flavor of queer to me
you just you can't
it's like they're a shape shifter they
are inherently non-binary and or gender
fluid
uh oh rain yeah rain rain is queer on
every level uh absolutely
Lilith
Lilith Lil Miss a little queer
like if you had asked me say at the end
uh or towards the end of season two I
might have put her in closeted but I
think I think she's she's a little queer
oh kikimura you're just you're awful get
get down there with the homophobes and
and take your boss with you like heat
Bellows would be the words actually
here's here's a funny thing about this
so Bellows inherently just because of
what is moral compass is when he comes
from and all that homophobe
straight up no question the thing is I'm
not sure kikimura would be inherently
but she would be because Bellows is
because she's just that kind of boot
licking toady
so it's like it sounds weird to say
homophobic to feel more included but
that's kind of the feeling I get from
her
yeah
uh
Hootie
how how queer do we want to say
hoodie is uh
oh that one is kind of tricky
hmm
hoodie
is too weird
to be anything other than up at the top
especially when they're going to use an
image with that friggin grin
like that grin of all things he is he is
a chaos queer
that is what hoodie is
oh
yeah
what what a mess
he's a glorious mess a principal bump
he's he's a little queer he's a little
bit
I don't it's not something he dwells on
he doesn't he doesn't share that aspect
of his life too much but it's there it's
there a little bit yeah
Lewis's mom
Ally an amazing Ally like the best mom
Ally with absolutely love her she's
fantastic
oh Steve
what we do with you
um I'm gonna put Steve in closeted but
kind of for the same reason everyone
else is in there because I'm not really
using on this tier I'm not really using
closeted to mean like
knows what they are and have shut
themselves down more a sort of uh still
figuring themselves out is kind of what
I'm using that for I'd I'd honestly
rename the the tier if I was making this
myself
Basha
she gives off
mean girl bisexual vibes
so we're gonna go with a little queer
The Collector
ah
now see like if this was set up the way
the Marvel one was I just slot him under
asexual and call it a day
um but since that's not the way this
one's settled I gotta decide whether he
fits under a little queer or Queer on
every level and that's hmm
[Music]
hmm
that is
tricky
I mean
I think I gotta go queer in every level
and ultimately I know this is a
reductive reason but
in the end
I mean look at him
at
I don't think anybody would go maybe
that person's straight
yeah I know he's got to go up there
uh trying to remember what the heck this
guy's name is starts with a D
ah I don't remember he he's he's
real flamboyant
um
I think I gotta go up there now here's
the thing I feel really awkward
I don't know who the hell that is
like I'm legitimately confused by who
the hell that is I've been in the
background in the back of my head
this whole time trying to figure out who
is that
I don't know if I've just got like a
complete Blank Spot in my head for some
reason but
I have no idea
who that is I don't
I don't remember
who that is
I'm actually gonna hop over the chat see
if I can get some help
uh on that oh and I'll address uh Super
Chat while I'm here from John vinyls
once again thank you very much
um I re-watched your positive
masculinity video recently I've been
wondering if there are any male
characters in The Owl House and or in
fibia who might exemplify positive
masculinity ooh that's a good question
oh
B's girlfriend oh
right
all right we're gonna go uh
uh we're gonna go a little like
definitely queer but not like whoa
all right that's what oh
that's I mean that's why I didn't
remember I haven't re-watched the see
the third season specials
um I've only watched them The Once and
that's that's you know what I think what
I helped did they put a background I
think if they've given her a background
I'd seen the character and I might have
been able to to remember who the heck
she was but put her on a white
background did me no favors uh as far as
that goes
um let's
let's see so John vinyls your question
positive masculinity in the owl house
and or amphibia
ah
so
potentially I'd have to I'd have to
think about it more
but
I think
um
I think principal bump
actually does a good job like having
that sort of
for lack of a better way to put it
classically masculine you know authority
figure energy
but especially as it goes on WE it's not
that even becomes softer we see the
softness that was always there and it's
always protective I feel like he would
fit certainly as I laid it out in that
video
amphibia
honestly as far as like
finding a positive way to do the
boys will be boys kind of character you
know rambunctious gets
you know goes out and plays in the in
the mudding gets a mess and I Sprague
might be
uh a solid fit for that
yeah
that could work
um sorry give me a second
and I think
it's a little bit sooner than I had
planned but we don't have time to do
another tier
so I think uh we're actually gonna wrap
it up there
so
um
was I know Vera has done burlesque but
what would she do if stops were pulled
out and she could go uh to on RuPaul's
Drag Race if she wanted I've I've kind
of broken away too much from drag
culture and it's not a style of like
they're it's hard to explain the
differences but there is just a general
feel of difference between burlesque and
drag or at least the kind of drag that's
on RuPaul and that's just not the kind
of performance I want to get back into
oh we got one more Super Chat jumped in
there also would you cite logs in
Depp or Benson in case oh God ah you
gotta you gotta explain to me what those
letters are because I am so bad are
those acronyms yes I am so bad at
acronyms and I can never ever remember
them
um
Exemplar is a positive masculinity or
them being gay automatically makes them
non-canonically masculine by default oh
well regardless of what the
um acronyms are uh no being gay does not
disqualify you from positive masculinity
um there are plenty of very masculine
gay characters and any
um projection of positive masculinity
again as I laid out in that video you
don't have to be straight for that you
know being gay does not de-masculinize
you it just doesn't
so no I don't think I don't think that
that would be the case but um thank you
for the super chats thank you for
joining me folks I hope everybody
has a wonderful Pride this was a fun way
to kick it off
um there will be a new tattoo Doctor Who
on Wednesday
um I'll also be streaming on Twitch
Wednesday and Friday as per usual
Thursday is uh should be a new session
of quill and sword the DND campaign I'm
in that's also on Twitch and uh there'll
be some stuff going up in the break room
um and yeah that's what's coming up most
immediately I hope everybody takes care
oh and if you happen to be in the
Burlington Vermont area I will be
hosting uh untapped in Winooski at the
monkey house on Friday and I will be
hosting
um the Green Mountain Cabaret Show at
Main Street Main Street Landing in
Burlington on Saturday so I've got
another busy weekend performance wise
but everybody Take Care thank you so
much for coming and please remember that
you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you're the council and I'm just running
the meetings until next time this
Council
is adjourned oh John Violet snuck in
shows our dead end and kippo oh yeah no
being gay doesn't disqualify them
definitely not thank you for getting
that in at the last minute I'm sorry I'm
so bad at acronyms bye